brian there's so much frustration out
there and eight news now is getting a
lot of these calls a lot of these emails
and our joe moeller has been going
through them one
by one trying to get many of you the
answers you need
he is live tonight from the las vegas
strip with an update from dieter on many
of the issues that you might be having
joe that's right we're trying to get to
all those messages that we continue to
get but a lot of these questions have
been
regarding the lost wages assistance many
are wondering where week five of that is
we did submit some questions to dieter
and they did get back to us today
regarding that and a number of other
topics but let's start with the lost
wages
regarding week five that is still being
paid out peter says that could take
another 10 days to process so if you
don't see it
that is why they did not explain why
there is such a delay
many are also thinking ahead and
wondering will there be a week six
well the answer as of now is no there is
no approval from fema yet
if they do get that they will update us
i've talked to a lot of people who
expressed how frustrating
waiting is one woman says her husband
received week five but she did not
actually could pay three bills a mine i
mean if our president
signed an executive order that we are to
get it i mean
somebody's not following instructions
and it's frustrating
when my husband wakes up goes oh i got
my fifth payment and i'm thinking well i
mean i'm happy for him
but i'm thinking where's mine we have
another
a few more updates we got from dieter
today as well with the pool program set
to expire on the 26th dieter provided us
updates they say they are waiting for
congress to make a decision and they are
hoping it is an extension of the program
in place to utilize the same online
platform
if you are waiting for an appeal while
the pool program ends dieter says they
will still be looking at those claims
and will resolve them even after
december 26. now we have
heard from so many people who are
waiting for their benefits and they're
struggling to get by doing whatever they
can
we did meet a woman in east las vegas
today we'll share her story about how
she's been waiting for nine months for
her benefits that's coming up
at six o'clock reporting live here on
this trip joe mohler 8 news now